but we begin with insults and
accusations flying tonight
between a group of house democrats and a
fellow democratic congresswoman ilhan
omar
it involves omar statements about the
u.s and israel likening them
to terror groups hamas and the taliban
we get blow by blow tonight from
correspondent kevin kor good evening
kevin evening brett the controversy
actually began when congresswoman omar
posted a tweet
appearing to summarize her virtual
exchange with secretary of state anthony
blinken in what some considered
fairly incendiary language her tweet
read in part quote
we have seen unthinkable atrocities
committed by the u.s
hamas israel afghanistan and the taliban
critics blasted what appeared to be
language equating the u.s and israel
with the hamas group and with the
taliban
in fact critics including several
members of her own party demanded that
omar
clarify her comments writing in part in
a statement the united states and israel
are imperfect
they went on to say this and like all
democracies at times deserving of
critique but
false equivalencies give cover to
terrorist groups
omar accusing her colleagues are
perpetuating quote islamic phobic
tropes calling the letter offensive and
adding that it's a
sign of harassment and silencing that
she finds unbearable
by the way in her clarification brett
she said i was in no way
equating terrorist organizations with
democratic countries
with well-established judicial systems
meanwhile fellow members of the squad
leapt to omar's defense including
aoc new york congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
accusing critics including those from
her party of intentionally distorting
omar's remarks pretty sick and tired
of the constant vilification intentional
mischaracterization
and public targeting of ilhan omar
coming from our caucus she added this
they have no concept for the danger they
put her in by skipping private
conversations
and leaping to fueling targeted news
cycles around her
added rashida talib freedom of speech
doesn't exist for muslim women in
congress
the benefit of the doubt doesn't exist
for muslim women in congress
house democratic leadership should be
ashamed of its relentless exclusive tone
policing
congresswoman of color democratic house
leadership
led by nancy pelosi issuing a statement
trying to quell the uproar they said
they quote
welcomed the clarification from the
congresswoman
right all right kevin thank you